play kill this dude can spit like this
too can wrap his [ __ ]
like he might die in the West Coast yeah
believe it was an MC Hey
and we go we gotta get you a we got to
get you the spits on [ __ ] nipsey hey
let's get it why don't you drop a drop
of B for my new to rap over Pharaoh come
on Pharaoh let's get it huh Oh way
lassic nas a rocky hustle come on Vegas
turn that beat up a little foamy turn it
up yeah yeah awesome flight awesome
awesome right yeah um Vegas what up the
the look I never take a break even when
other words I was married to the streets
and footers I got divorced so I just go
hard and let nature take its course the
cinematic wreckage is the lay quiet
story no see that's a cheap shot the jaw
shapes hosted these rappers now was no
boring some all hype
that's what I'm backing out the show
core hypo pipes and bullet food windows
mess around save your life they say oh
so you're the greatest I say you're
right I'm more confident than the shore
Mike I'm Ali Gretzky or Mike but a steel
or SC for life the [ __ ] week like
three days four nights and I'm the type
to bring the shotty to the sword fights
if the night first-class won't pour
flights and if innate this what is your
life is your life
narrator is what is your life awesome
boys one here no money out yo hey thanks
also Mike man I appreciate that topic a
colossal yeah hey yo real talk Nick yeah
I'm you know I got
you when I was out in Idaho yeah come a
long way since then both of us so what
pops my dude hey real quick I know you'd
be happy on the Twitter won't you let
everybody know then get in contact with
you yeah everything hips also with the
Twitter to myspace to Facebook
everything lips y'all so you spelling an
RT s ey H USS Elliott I let y'all help
us and tonight good night club I will be
there you need to be there anything else
is gonna be there no question Wow Thank
You blessing of Nick sir yeah Thank You
homie I'll see y'all next time south
central state of mind in stores 2010
call it radio requesting to record feel
good let's go